[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist got
chuck with me Chuck Nice how you doing
man hey doing well Neil thank you for
asking we got a Hot Topic today uh oh
psychedelics and Consciousness o oo H
well guess what uh one of them I really
uh I'm interested in okay I'm interested
in one of those things one of them okay
all right we have our expert about 10 on
this very subject uh he's been on Star
talk before George mure did I pronounce
your name correctly George yes you did
thank you excellent a chair of
anesthesiology and professor of
neurosurgery University of Michigan uh
you've taken a multidisciplinary
approach to Consciousness I have a
zillion questions about that and the
network mechanisms that Empower
Consciousness and possibly disrupt
unconsciousness yeah
and just all kinds of metrics of
Consciousness you're the guy is that is
that what made you want to be an
anesthesiologist or or was it the other
way around was was being an
anesthesiologist just uh sparking all
kinds of curiosity about Consciousness
or was it that you always had these uh
um wonderings about Consciousness and
that led you to being an
anesthesiologist yeah great question I
got interested in Consciousness studying
philosophy as an undergraduate
and uh decided to pursue medicine and
Neuroscience I actually started off in
Psychiatry with an interest in
psychoanalysis and then I switched over
into anesthesiology because I thought
that would be the best field to study
Consciousness because of the rich set of
tools that we have to modulate conscious
experience not not to mention the a
myriad of either willing or unwilling
subjects
I just George I like your phrase to
modulate their conscious experience you
mean knock them out just just say it
well but actually it depends because
there are certain procedures in which
you you try to um engineer the the state
if you will to be somewhere in between
Consciousness and unconsciousness
sometimes referred to as a Twilight
state to we'll totally get into that and
also this affects very real afflictions
uh nerve JY that people have um stroke
and so let's get right into this so uh
you you founded the Michigan psychedelic
Center Beyond everything we just said
because regular Consciousness was not
good enough for you
yeah I started off um studying
Consciousness I founded the center for
Consciousness science here at the
University of Michigan medical school in
2014 and we used anesthetics as a tool
tool to modulate the level of
Consciousness that's one key dimension
of Consciousness and the level of
Consciousness refers to the global state
of arousal so I'm awake somnolent
sleeping anesthetized comos brain dead
um and it's a very powerful set of tools
that we have but it's also limited
because it isn't really addressing
another key dimension of Consciousness
that is sometimes referred to as the
content of Consciousness that's what
we're actually experiencing the
qualitative aspects the redness of the
Rose the bless of the sky and this is
where psychedelics can come into play
because they don't have a major impact
on the level of Consciousness but they
certainly alter the way that we
experience things and the content of
Consciousness that's a whole other place
to go or my gosh on on the research
Frontier so Consciousness then if I
thought about it mathematically another
dimension of Consciousness is the
intensity with which you experience
reality is that a fair way to say that
um yes I think that would U fall under
that content of Consciousness and there
are a lot of different levels that we
could be talking about just basic
interceptive Consciousness consciousness
of the world consciousness of myself or
self-awareness right so and and tell me
in the the extreme limit of these
examples here you mentioned
what do people mean when they say it was
a medically induced coma can you measure
that as like the extreme limit of no
consciousness without being dead so I
mean one form of a medically induced
coma or a common form would involve some
sort of anesthetic agent like a
barbiturate or propofol for example
these intravenous anesthetics you can uh
in fact measure the state or at Le at
least the drug impact uh using the
electroencephalogram
EEG focused on brain waves and there are
certain uh characteristic morphologies
such as something called burst
suppression which is electrical quesence
punctuated by this high frequency High
amplitude activity that would suggest
that somebody does does not have the
capacity for Consciousness so I think
that would be one example of what is
referred to as a medically induced coma
what exactly are you measuring uh
electrically is it the firing of neurons
in a certain part of the brain like what
exactly is the
metric yeah that that's a great question
first of all I want to be clear that
even though we're measuring things not
everything is reducible to a single
metric or measurement and Chuck to your
question it really depends on the scale
it depends on the experimental settings
so in the laboratory we might be able to
um measure neuronal activity at a single
unit level for example on the non-human
primate brain of which we've done in our
research group with our collaborators in
humans we're going to be using typically
scalp EEG to measure electrical
activity there's also
magnetoencephalography that's measuring
magnetic waves there's functional
magnetic resonance imaging which is a
neuroim form so there are a variety of
different scales and neuroimaging
techniques that people evaluate when
they're trying to uh assess uh an impact
of a drug for example on Consciousness
and then a whole Suite of analytic
techniques thereafter uh to try to parse
through that data let's back up
so let let me be the thousandth person
to ask you uh what is
consciousness yeah how should we think
about it yeah great great question um I
don't know if I can really give you an
answer but on the other hand it's
something that we all know uh from the
first person perspective it's a sense of
experience subjectivity interiority a
point of view uh some people have
defined it operationally one philosopher
is uh what we lose at night when we go
into a dreamless sleep and what we Reg
the next morning when we wake up oh wow
um often times in the clinical setting
we have to operationalize this through
behavioral
assessment Neil Chuck I don't have
access to your firstperson phenomenology
but I can make some
inferences uh about your State of
Consciousness based on your
interactivity um and we do this all day
we we basically are making inferences
about the state of someone else's
subjectivity based on their objective
behavior that usually works but there's
certain
situations um certainly in medicine
where there can be a Divergence between
responsiveness and
Consciousness so the fact that the
bookshelves are
filled with people writing with titles
Consciousness explained for example
doesn't that mean we don't really
understand Consciousness as long as
people continue to write books on it
because I can tell you that in in
physics you know there's like three
books on gravity on the shelf right
we're not still writing books on
Newton's laws of gravity so so we're
done there and we're on to other things
so isn't the activity in the field a
measure of how much we don't know more
than a measure of how much we do yeah I
think that's fair to say and certainly
if if you compare it to physics and the
long history of physics um or other
disciplines the modern science of
Consciousness as we know it and we talk
about it really started to coales in the
1990s now of course people have been
asking the question why are we aware of
ourselves and the world since people
have been able to ask questions but in
terms of the modern science it really
started to emerge in the
1990s for most of the 20th century
Consciousness was really marginalized
even
delegitimized as a topic of scientific
inquiry largely through the infuence of
behaviorism and
psychoanalysis but then in the
1980s some say it say it frud that's
right you said it that's fine yeah tell
me tell me how you really feel about
your mom and
cocaine and cigars right yes I'm not
going to address that but many
implications yeah but actually yeah so
Freud said the Consciousness is merely
the tip of the iceberg and probably was
correct in terms of of how much
cognitive activity is going on outside
of our uh conscious uh realm uh but in
the 1980s there were some really
prominent scientists and intellectuals
that started to publicly turn their
attention to Consciousness Nobel laurat
Francis Crick Nobel laurat Gerald
Edelman one of the Nobel Prize for work
in Immunology um mathematical physicist
Roger Penrose who won the Nobel Prize a
few years ago I know not I know I know
and I know I don't need to tell you this
I believe for his work on black holes
yeah yes but they started to turn their
attention to this in a public way and
that helped to uh confer legitimacy so
it it's fairly young and uh despite the
fact that we're learning a lot and
Neuroscience has really advanced in
terms of
neuroimaging the ability to manipulate
neural circuits to image them at the uh
at the animal level we're still asking
fundamental questions like right there
it is are the neural coret of
Consciousness in the front of the brain
or in the back of the brain literally
like where is consciousness located that
course in terms of large swaths of
Cortex and most recently there's been a
big Kur fuffle in the field
um with respect to one very
well-developed um theory of
Consciousness that has been called out
or Accused by
124 individuals of being pseudoscience
and this is um this is a theory that's
been around for almost two decades so it
just gives you a sense of the state of
the field it is relatively speaking in
its nent phases certainly compared to
disciplines such as physics so then
you'd expect there to be the wild west
and that's not a bad thing it's just the
reality of a newly born field in a way
it's kind of a cool thing it's kind of
cool right right right why are all these
people who want to deny Consciousness to
other animals like anyone who's owned a
cat or a dog will never deny them a full
consciousness of what's going on
especially a cat we know that cats now
dogs okay I'm listen I love plotting
your death when you see that cat
actually calling your lawyer to see if
it is a benefici on your insurance you
know that that cat is
conscious that's right basically what
they're do so so what is where does that
come from is it the size of our frontal
lobe and relative to that of other
animals because yeah we all know cats
don't have a farhead right so so what
that's that that is such a great
question and that that Taps into this uh
bigger question and I've alluded to it
earlier which is
how do we know uh someone or something
is conscious or not so on the one hand
you have some who would assert that only
human beings are capable of
Consciousness um and again this is where
definition is important because some
people might actually be referring to
self-awareness there are others and not
just in the philosophical realm but in
the neuroscientific realm who are
bordering more on what is called pans
psychism which suggests
that everything in the universe to some
degree has some level of Consciousness
it's like a molecular Consciousness yeah
so how do we um how do we figure this
out and you brought up animals as kind
of an example in between well this is
where it's really important for us as a
field to try to identify and some are
trying to do this you know what are the
fundamental characteristics of a
conscious system that we can measure
independently of behavior
um because again we're making inferences
based on Behavior even if you're
describing your interaction with a dog
or a cat you're making inference based
on their behavior but how can we figure
out a behavior independent way to assess
the systems capacity for Consciousness
because then we could apply that to
someone who for example we think is in a
vegetative state but might not be or
somebody that we think is anesthetized
in the operating room but they're only
paralyzed right or a species that can't
communicate with us or babies I was
going to say because really where you
need to go first is babies because their
Consciousness uh is emerging I don't
know if it's emergent because that would
be all of us but a different word it's a
different word but it is emerging
because when you have an infant you
couldn't necessarily say that that
infant is conscious of the world around
it it's conscious or aware of itself but
you know that as another human being
that it is definitely going to be that
barring any kind of brain malady or
cataclysmic event that would stop it
from happening yeah you can take that
question even earlier and think about
the prenatal in utero phase where there
is electrical activity where there are
uh um dynamics of um brain activity that
might potentially a sustain experience
and obviously this is a question with
major ethical implications as well the
other the other place where this is
going to come up so you know the big
problem used to be we think someone is
unconscious because of their behavior
they're unresponsive but they're
actually conscious and I give you an
example someone we think is anesthetized
or we think is in a vegetative state but
now there's another problem that's
emerging or that will emerge and that is
now we have artificial systems that are
highly responsive and will'll get more
and more responsive and now people are
going to start asking the question well
is this responsiveness driven in part by
some kind of sension and again that's
where we need these tools to assess does
this system in a principled way have the
capacity for Consciousness we're all
going to
die a takes
over that's the answer to all that's the
answer to all of
it tell me about the importance because
I've read papers on this the importance
to you as a neuroscientist and a
Consciousness expert of an animal
recognizing itself in a mirror yes so I
me this is something that goes back to
Darwin who while he was thinking and and
um theorizing and investigating by
biological evolution was also thinking
about cognitive uh and mental Evolution
um and that um mirror recognition test
has often been used and I'm not an
expert in that so I I want to be clear
about this um to assess some sort of
self um reference
self-recognition um and this is
interesting in terms of applying it to
um not just primates but also some Aven
species and you know some would posit
that there there have been multiple
lines of
evolution not not exactly the same thing
as the cortex as we know it the Aven
pallum but a kind of similar functional
organization so I think this comes up in
terms of trying to identify you know
where across the timeline of
philogyny uh did Consciousness emerge
and the other question is is it is it an
all or none phenomenon is it graded is
there a Continuum because like I mean
think about it if a bird may see itself
in a mirror and go oh that's not another
bird you know that's that's just me but
that doesn't mean that it then Ponders
why it is its own existence its own
existence you know so you know some of
this is a matter of
intelligence as opposed to consciousness
yes it could be and and actually your
your comment Chuck um also leads to a
reflection on different categories of
Consciousness theories because uh some
theories are referred to as perceptual
others are cognitive and one question
that comes up is interesting does
Consciousness itself
require some of the cognitive functions
that we have such as attention or
working memory or or is it it just kind
of a purely perceptive phenomenon oh
let's talk about G high I'll get to that
minute just a quick second here hold on
I've been saving that for the end of
this conversation I'm sitting here just
like when are we getting to it I want to
get the
foundations established here that's why
you're a
scientist um so if we don't really
understand
Consciousness in on a very detailed
level we're not in a
position
to
establish that what's going on in
computers is consciousness right can can
we are are your tools yeah useful even
if we don't know what it is that's going
on to say that a computer has achieved
Consciousness right how would we know
well that that's the question when
people say when people will ask me do
you think computers are can be
conscious my response is how will we
know and again that's where we need to
figure out what what is the system
that's required and does that system
need to be neural does it need to be
neurobiological or can you simply have a
functional arrangement of information
processors that could achieve the same
outcome so I would say we do not know
that so let me ask you this then based
on what Neil just asked and what you
just said if we were
have the computing power like a quantum
computer and we were able to replicate
down to the very Neuron a human brain so
you have this trillion connections all
firing at once and and you're able to
program into it exactly everything that
uh the person that you're mapping was
thinking and so forth would that then be
sensient or would that just be a
replication of sensient it's a great
question and I don't have an answer um
CH you're not supposed to stump the
guest that's not why you're on the show
no but great yeah great to explore um
and you know there there are a few
things that go along with that one is
you know we think about it exclusively
related to the brain but what about what
about the body what about the
interaction with the environment so
those environmental factors are
critically important as well but also to
the point is you know we don't know yet
what is generating the conscious
experience and we can look at lots of
different network models um and we can
look at different principles across
different systems but some of these
systems are conscious and others aren't
so they're they're clear Network
phenomena that are going on in the
conscious brain that get disrupted
during
unconsciousness but there are similar
Network phenomena going on in
non-biological systems that we don't
think are conscious so very important
question in G ebach do you remember
Douglas hofstead yes in that book which
I think one a pol surprise very thick
very fascinating book uh in the end he
has a conversation with Einstein's brain
oh and he imagines this is this is like
decades before people thought of that
we're in a simulation or anything he
imagined removing Einstein's brain but
preserving every single neurosynaptic
um Capac all the neurosynaptic capacity
of that brain okay so it's in a jar and
so now you ask it a question you say
Albert um you know what time does Grand
Central Station arrive at the next train
okay that'd be like a fun relativity
question everything Everything's
Relative but whatever you pick a
question and then that question goes in
through acoustic signals to the op to
the to the whatever the acoustic nerves
that connect with the brain and you
watch it trip circuits throughout the
brain and if you had it perfectly
modeled you should be able to
follow how that question lands and how
it triggers a response where then
Einstein's brain speaks back is that in
principle something that could happen
one day do you
think yeah I mean you know I I don't
know if I'm answering your question but
first of all you know this brain and a
vat concept um really in many respects
goes back to day C when he was uh
reflecting on whether he could just be
completely deceived by everything that
he was
experiencing but um yes there are ways
of mapping the information processing
from as you said the primary and the
this case auditory cortex to higher
order cortices these different volleys
or reverberations of activity um Can in
course ways be mapped um but then again
again the question comes up is that
associated with experience because I
could I can put the same questions into
chat GPT right now that's going to have
its own processing capability and it
could give me the same answer as
Einstein's brain in this thought EXP
experiment through a completely
different mechanism that we presume is
non-conscious got it okay very good all
right so now let's get to the meat of
this conversation sorry there could be
vegetarians out there let's get to the
carrots of this
conversation um I never thought before
today and the notes for this
conversation how
psychedelics could
be Tools in your utility belt to probe
the conscious mind and that fascinates
me greatly so you would measure certain
quantities of
psychedelics in uh get a willing subject
to ingest them and then measure the
consequences of that and their awareness
and reaction to the physical world
around them so that seems like an
entirely un is that an unexplored
Frontier for the neuroscientist as
opposed to just the the person who wants
drug experiences yes great question so
obviously many of these naturally
occurring psychedelics have been used
for Millennia and spiritual uh practices
and
rituals but of course there was all
already in in western civilization a a
first wave of intense interest uh in
psychedelics as a tool to understand the
mind the brain and and for therapeutic
purposes and this is something that was
happening in the 1950s and 60s and of
course we know how that turned out in
terms of the the late
60s uh the the enthusiasm started to
extend far beyond the rigor and sense of
responsibility to say Woodstock things
were made
illegal um around 1970 and then the
field really just became dormant under
President Nixon if I remember correctly
the drug rules got all readjusted right
yeah yeah that makes makes sense now we
are really experiencing what has been
referred to as the Psychedelic
Renaissance because right on in the past
10 to 15 years uh there's been a
Resurgence of neuroscientific
Investigation um there has been a
Resurgence of clinical investigation
with rigorous clinical trials that are
testing psychedelic
uh for conditions like depression these
articles are getting published in the
New England Journal the Lancet major
medical journals uh in the field um and
obviously social attitudes have been
changing policy has been changing with
decriminalization and cannabis has
probably led the way a bit on this so we
really are in the midst of a Renaissance
again this is something that was already
a matter of intense interest but now we
have a lot of
uh tools such as neuroimaging for
example lots of analytic tools um
theoretical constructs uh to explore
psychedelics and to help us understand
this spectrum of conscious States now
I'm an
anesthesiologist and I actually I want
to state with humility that I wouldn't
consider myself the foremost psychodelic
neuroscientists there are great people
out there doing great work but if you
think about Anese Aesthetics and
psychedelics they're kind of mirror
images of one another and they help us
probe our model of the world brain
function so anesthetics suppress
Consciousness right they contract the
repertoire of accessible brain States or
configurations they reduce
neurophysiologic complexity
psychedelics one could say they give us
a higher
Consciousness uh they exp ele
Consciousness they expand the repertoire
of accessible brain States and they
enhance neurophysiologic wait wait wait
wait but but you know the brain barely
works as it is in as a measure of of as
a tool to measure objective reality you
know if it worked any if it worked
better we wouldn't have have optical
illusions books right where simple line
drawings completely confound Your
Capacity to know what is objectively
true and what isn't wouldn't have pen
and
Teller illusionists right would that
wouldn't exist right so so why would
stirring chemicals into the
brain give you a more accurate
understanding of the brain rather than a
less accurate
one yeah so that great question and and
there are a couple of Dimensions there
first of all what is consciousness doing
in the first place your point is it a
mirror for reality or objective reality
as you said I don't necessarily think
that's the case um there are lots of
different ways that you can think about
it you can think about the pr the brain
as a sensory processing organ but others
would suggest that the brain is really
creating uh this conscious experience it
helps us get through the world helps us
achieve the biological goals and the
brain is essentially like a hypothesis
and model making machine it generates a
mental model it uses sensory information
uh to give feedback to that model so I
think what what the drugs are doing in
in One Direction or another is not so
much helping us understand um you know
the brain Visa objective reality but
just how the brain functions in terms of
its own models in its own capacity for
Consciousness an Institute tool an
Institute tool makes sense cuz anybody
who's seen a picture of themselves for
real understands that uh instruments
that measure reality objectively can
really mess you up because I see a
picture of me and I'm like I do not look
I'm not this ugly I am not this ugly but
that is because when I look in the
mirror my brain is creating a construct
for what it says this is what I look
like but the camera is just like n you
ugly bro sorry okay so CH you should
sign up for one of his sounds like you
need
help all right so the dosing matters
greatly here and if people's brains are
roughly similar you would expect similar
reactions to similar drugs and perhaps
similar dosing but I bet that's not the
case could you explain why sure I think
the the dose does matter and people are
exploring what is necessary for example
for a therapeutic effect can you do
micro doing
um that doesn't really have a major
impact on
Consciousness um some actually are
exploring whether you need to have a
psychoactive experience at all maybe
there are aspects of these drugs that
are having a therapeutic effect
independently of the Psychedelic
experience that's just which of course
is the case with marijuana you separate
out the ingredients there and they have
very different utilities right and and
that's being explored as a um as a noble
drug class I think the other thing about
psychedelics and this goes back to the
Timothy lery days is the concept of set
and setting um that unlike other drug
classes where maybe you give dose X and
you get response why obviously it's
going to vary across the population uh
but with psychedelics the the set or the
mindset going into the experience and
the setting or the environment yeah can
have a major influence on what the
subjective
experience even at a similar dose in the
same person going into it you know in a
certain mood or with a certain
orientation having this at a hospital
versus a naturalistic setting could
evoke very different kinds of experien
good trip bad trip exactly exactly so if
you're successful um if you're supremely
successful in this exercise you and your
colleagues um and I've said this but
only because it felt like it would be
true not cuz I really knew if you're
successful in treating mental health we
won't need
psychologists or psychologists in the
future because you just go into the
brain and fix the brain rather than oh
lay on the couch and talk to me for
three hours a week and do that for three
years and maybe we'll you'll be cured
yeah you're you're coming at it from a
whole other place so I've said this I've
gotten only mild push back because I
think deep down people know it could be
true if not will be true that psychology
is to
Neuroscience as Alchemy is to chemistry
oo well that's not good for psychologist
I'm not faulting Alchemist they bet on
the wrong horse bet yeah but they kept
notes and they the foundations of the
early periodic table were there you know
but we learn no there there's a better
way to do this a more reliable way so
did you just React to what I just said
I'm reacting right now innal um yeah so
it's it's a great question and and
another way I want to just reframe this
is you know what is the mechanism of
therapeutic action of the psychedelics
and there are a couple of different
possibilities some would say it's just
the drug in the brain there's something
that's going on at the molecular level
it's going to induce
neuroplasticity maybe dentritic spine
arborization and neurons and we can
engineer a drug that doesn't even have
to have any experience others would say
well it's not just the drug in the brain
it's the experience that the drug evokes
and there is something that the person
and the Brain learns about itself
through that experience and That's
essential and others might say no it is
actually the therap it's the therapeutic
intervention it's the
Psychotherapy the drug is just creating
the conditions for growth but it's the
therapy that's actually doing the work
or it might be some combination so it's
kind of kind of like planting planting a
a a a field you you got to prepare the
ground you got to have the seeds you
have to have the water all these things
come together you know it's not just one
of those things I don't know the answer
but it's an empirical question and if we
find out that these so-called
nonhallucinogenic psychedelic analoges
or psychop plast can have an impact on
depression without any therapy and
without any Associated psychedelic
experience that would help us answer it
so it is an empirical question I think
it is being invested we are seeing some
some evidence not necessarily of that
per se but there is some evidence
pointing towards that when you look at
PTSD patients who go through these
psychedelic experiences many of them
basically say I don't have PTSD anymore
yes well there there certainly is
empirical evidence that some of the
protocols used in these trials which
often include a psychedelic drug support
during the Psychedelic experience and
then Psychotherapy or integration
afterwards are effective and what's
unique I think and what differentiates
uh psychedelics from traditional
anti-depressant um
medications is that they can sometimes
have an impact that's durable beyond the
drug being in your body ask after a
single session as to a
traditional uh anti-depressant might
take four to six weeks for a mood effect
psilocin or ketamine it's almost
immediate and that's important if you
think about somebody who's acutely
suicidal or who might be in a pallative
care situation with cancer that's the
other area where these cancer patients
go through these psychedelic experiences
and they come out of it and
invariably that they come out and say
I'm cool now I I'm I'm not afraid to die
anymore I'm no longer overly anxious or
no longer anguish about the fact that I
know I have a terminal disease that's
incredible yes and that that is uh one
area trying to treat or or help
existential distress uh in the dying
process again uh was explored in the
1960s is being actively explored again
with psychedelics so I'm delighted to
just bear witness to the birth of a
field and watching this unfold in real
time right in front of our eyes and I I
have friends who were micro doing and
who had neurological emotional
challenges and they only speak highly of
that experience and so uh to the extent
that science continues with with phase
one two three trials whatever is
necessary in the field uh I look forward
to where this is going doc I got to ask
you and this is the the most important
question we got to wrap we got okay I'm
well then I'm glad I'm getting this
question in CU it's seriously important
okay where where do I get these
drugs he's got a van out
back a good time to wrap
up offline we will
learn yeah I do I do need to say and
this is important that you know we are
really trying to adhere to the most
rigorous the most responsible standards
in our work um I'm looking at the big
picture and the and the long game uh
it's great to be enthusiastic but we
also have to be self-critical if we want
this to become part of mainstream
medicine and so my tagline always is we
shouldn't stigmatize psychedelic
research neither should we romanticize
it we need to treat this with
seriousness just like we would any other
drug research that is a sentence to end
a show on right there well if I ever
heard one there it is Dr George marure
thanks for being back on Star Talk
Delight catch up on what you're doing in
your field you and your colleagues and
keep up the good work uh like I said
that's a whole we're witnessing the
birth of a branch of science that could
be just become commonplace and routine
in the decades to come and please send
me a send me an email on where I can get
those S
[Music]
sample let's end this before Chuck loses
all right well this has been Star Talk
Neil degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist all about psychedelics
and Consciousness again uh doc thanks
for being on the show Chuck always good
to have you man always a pleasure all
right Neil the grass Tyson here as
always keep looking
[Music]
up